apple has just officially announced  their iphone 14 event happening next  month on september 7th with the tagline  far out with an image of the universe  and the galaxy's creating an apple logo  and a lot of people are thinking this is  probably meaning the astrophotography  mode on the new iphone 14 pro especially  because it's getting a 48 megapixel  camera but mark german thinks there's a  simpler explanation because this is the  farthest out they've ever announced an  apple event in the past two weeks from  today but there's also the chance that  it could be meaning that we're getting a  one more thing sneak peek into a future  product coming a few months from now  especially since the chinese version of  the invitation literally translates to  forward looking so i am super excited  and we are going to be getting the  iphone 14 lineup with four different  models as well as three apple watch  models so let me know if you're excited  down below